[Music]
I seen this next one already Marsh
this is gonna be angry oh this is bad
this is really really bad I I'm I'm by
the way since we have the chord scene
I'm skipping Frozen stupid laugh
um
but I will I will still play it so this
is the third one
[Music]
this is Crowder
yeah oh [ __ ] you oh no
cute without the bro so that's doing emo
cut acute without the e is that what
he's doing yes hey guys guys guys what's
the name of the band taking back Mug's
day get plugged the mugs
hey Crowder I know Crowder's on Rumble
let me remind you of something we're not
locked in here with you you're locked in
here with us yes
[Music]
I know exactly what oh my God oh my God
oh
it's like
you know what Crowder look when you were
doing bad covers of like Neil Diamond
and like doing your little kiss kiss
you know all that [ __ ] I was like okay
you know whatever
now he's [ __ ] on my youth
now you're [ __ ] on my youth
and I took that personally I took that
[ __ ] personally
[Music]
oh man you won't like his mug Trail
parody
and his mugger line Trio cover that he's
doing
I will be Avenged seven mugs I've been
seven months is gonna be great
I'm putting it out there right now what
about mukfoot
Bullet for My valence mug Crowder what
about mug with Rome
from first to mug
I wanna I wanna make it very clear as I
lay mug
sorry go ahead first
Crowder if you go near the trio oh [ __ ]
oh I want I will [ __ ] end you
I will see to it that I will I will make
it my life's work to destroy your life
in every conceivable way if you don't if
you ever do an Alkaline Trio song
you don't want to hear the mug Club Trio
um
what about Jimmy eat what about Jimmy
Eat mug a little Hawthorne mugs my
Hawthorne mugs was good that's mug for
Cutie Hey when's Crowder gonna do a Tim
pool cover let's just [ __ ] get the
world over with what about yellow mug oh
yellow Mug's not bad I like giggle
you could tell when we grew up huh
what about puddle of mug
puddle of mug is amazing sorry man I
need something hard for I'm worried to
mug vein oh mug veins not bad
hey have you guys heard that band slip
mug oh slip bug's great oh okay come on
August Burns mugs but that's it last one
we're done we're done now okay what
about mug talica okay mug talic is not a
bad Banner right what about mug attack
what about mugs and roses
you're a [ __ ] hack you're such a hat
Crowder Ozzy mugborne's famous album
[ __ ] blizzard of mug oh [ __ ]
oh my God
it's a Sheamus guitarist died before
they got to finish Diary of a mugman
okay let's go come on
okay Breathe Here We Go Oh wait we
missed an obvious one mug vein oh no
they did that they did oh did we do yeah
I think that's the best one okay did
somebody do mug shroomhead no no they
didn't see that's a good one that's a
good one no we do you do mug but written
in the corn script with the G backwards
we're getting mug Garden
oh [ __ ] Allison mug
and muggly crew but now we're done good
luck Tara okay notorious mug but now
we're done
mudkins
you guys remember that feud between
notorious mug and two cup okay
two cups
this is so stupid that was all mug
Knight's fault okay
[Laughter]
he set him up
oh
[Laughter]
mug the police coming straight from the
underground all right we're done
you fat [ __ ]
our mug puns are funnier than anything
you've ever done Crowder
oh all right we're done we're done okay
Iron Man Out Of The Clock we beat you
frozen oh that's right we're done ah yes
we defeated you don't have to do it we
don't have to do it we defeated you
Frozen
thank you mug puns that saved us that's
not breaking bad it's like what happened
I won
saying you guys could join the mug fun
today for just 99 a year say mug name
um